there was a clip that went viral I
wanted to play it all week and we got
distracted with some other things but
it's a really really fascinating clip
Patrick Bet David who is a finance guy
and has a really fantastic podcast he
had uh Neil deGrasse Tyson on and Neil
deGrasse Tyson is I guess what we would
call a science Communicator he goes on
Bill Maher all the time he's the sort of
darling of the mainstream media to
explain science to people sort of in the
Bill Nye the Science Guy mold and uh and
he talks about physics and astronomy and
a whole bunch where he's sort of a
modern day Carl Sagan kind of thing and
he went on Patrick's podcast and they
started talking about vaccines and
efficacy and personal responsibility and
it's a really really great moment here
the clip's about a minute long
if you want to get an abortion get an
abortion if I want to get the vaccine I
get to choose so you can't force if I
can force you to get an abortion you
shouldn't be able to force it because
it's not about you it's about people you
interact with and that's the social
contract of public we don't we don't
even know with the vaccine worked or not
at the time yes that's what the trials
are dude that's why these childhood are
you missing data out but but let me ask
you a question are we saying only one
type of scientists are right no we're
saying that the system in place the 16
000 that's signed up no no the system in
place to test vaccines
there's an entire
system that's in place
that that with review boards and all of
it and the average that's in place now
you can say you can what you can say is
I I have a better idea than all these
review boards and all these agencies and
the CDC I have a better idea here's what
you should do and that would have made
everything better okay you can put forth
that idea but what I'm saying is
in a case where you can contaminate
someone else it's not about you it's
about the collective you're assuming
Health you're assuming you're assuming
because somebody can take the vaccine uh
won't get coveted which by the way I
don't need to play the clips for you to
see it where everybody said hey if you
get it you're not going to get if you
take the vaccine you're not going to get
a Rachel Maddow Joe Biden I can give you
Fouche I can give you fit and you've
seen these clips before it's not like
you've never seen it before yeah what
happened they were wrong hold on so
so
um
The Strain evolved
man there's so much more of that but I
mean Tyson basically gets demolished he
he in essence demolishes himself
Patrick's a great interviewer he wasn't
trying to get him he was actually just
laying out some facts there but I want
to start with something he said towards
the end there there's a system in place
and what that made me think is you know
Tyson is also a very well-known atheist
and I believe that people have to
believe in something one way or another
so once he took away any belief system
as an atheist he had to believe in the
system so he had to believe that the
trials and the tests and the things that
the scientists and experts said were
going to work because it is in human
nature to believe something if you'd
like more sane takes on our insane World
check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live round tables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell